one of the biggest revelations of the
leaks published by Assange concern
alleged u.s. war crimes in Afghanistan
the International Criminal Court has
been looking into similar accusations
for a while now but has just decided not
to open an investigation into the matter
the ICC claims that doing so now would
be counter productive the judges decided
that investigation into the situation in
Afghanistan at this stage would not
serve the interests of Justice the ICC
noted the lack of cooperation that the
prosecutor has received which is likely
to go scare sir should an investigation
be authorised hampering the chances of
successful investigation and prosecution
while the US president Donald Trump
hailed the decision as quote a major
international victory for the rule of
law Washington recently revoked an entry
visa for the prosecutor responsible for
the probe citing the need to protect the
country's sovereignty the US has refused
to sign up to the ICC with officials
lashing out at the court we will not
cooperate with the ICC we will provide
no assistance to the ICC and Lee
certainly will not join the ICC as far
as America is concerned the ICC has no
jurisdiction no legitimacy and no
authority we will ban its judges and
prosecutors from entering the United
States
the ICC claims near universal
jurisdiction over the citizens of every
country the United States will use any
means necessary to protect our citizens
and those of our allies from unjust
prosecution by this illegitimate court
well the ICC opened an initial
investigation into the issue in 2006
this looked at allegation that over
10,000 civilians were killed in
atrocities as well as claims of torture
and rape in 2017 the ICC prosecutor
asked judges to take things further to
saying that there were reasonable
grounds to suspect the US military was
implicated Human Rights Watch says the
courts decision to reject a proper
investigation does
and bad precedent the ICC dodges
rejection of an Afghanistan
investigation is a devastating blow for
victims who have suffered Grievous
crimes without redress the judges logic
effectively allows member countries to
opt out of cooperating with the court
anti-war activist Sergio Cucho Gein says
the ICC has no power against the u.s.
don't think that an entity like an ICC
would be able to bring those charges to
the front and I think if we look back I
mean you take on Yugoslavia you take on
small countries in Africa maybe
countries in Latin America maybe
countries in South Asia but taking on
the United States I mean Ireland I mean
I guess the president do that would be a
case with the signs right now this is
this is not only Afghanistan but we have
to look at did they do they do anything
about Iraq no that was illegal
occupation illegal invasion just like
Afghanistan this case is not the first
case that points that out I think there
are a few cases that point going back to
even the crimes in Yugoslavia that the
NATO committed I think there's quite a
few cases and there's quite a few
precedents to show that ICC is actually
not capable of bringing the real actors
so the Western countries they had
Germans to the table and actually
charging them with crimes
you